التطورات الاحدث
ولعل ابرز ما نقلته الينا خلال هذه الساعه
هو خبر استشهاد الصحفي عصام اللولو اضافه
الى عدد من افراد عائلته وهو ما يرفع عدد
الشهداء من الجسم الصحفي فقط الى 121 منذ
بدايه الحرب الاسرائيليه على
غزه هذا صحيح محمد اعلن رسميا عن شهاد
الصحفي عصام اللولو وابنه محمد وزوجته
واحد ابنائه في غاره اسرائيليه طالت شاليه
ياوي عشرات النازحين في منطقه الزوايده
الواقعه غربي المنطقه الوسطى من قطاع غزه
هذه الغاره كانت امس الاد بحسب المصادر
الطبيه الفلسطينيه وبذلك يرتفع عدد
الشهداء الصحفيين على مستوى القطاع منذ
بدء الحرب على قطاع غزه الى
121 شهيدا وايضا في مقابل ذلك نعود الحديث
عن مدينه مينه غزه التي شهرت في الساعات
الاخيره اشتباكات واصوات اطلاق نار سمعت
بشكل واضح في محيط مجمع الشفاه الطبي وحي
الرمال وبعضا من الطلقات الناريه طالت
المقبره الجماعيه في ساحه مجمع الشفاه
الطبه الان عوده الهدوء تدريجيا الى محيط
المجمع وربما لم تعد تسمع اليات اسرائيليه
حسب شهود العيان الذين تحدثوا معنا قبل
قليل من داخل المجمع وكانوا محاصرين في
الساعات الماضيه وكل من كان ي حاول التحرك
كان يتعرض لاطلاق النار سواء من المسيرات
او من قبل الاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه
التي ربما بدات بالتراجع تدريجيا فلم تعد
تسمع وسبق هذه الغارات عفوا سبق هذا
التوغل الاسرائيلي المفاجئ واطلاق النار
غارات جويه اسرائيليه طالت مناطق عده من
مدينه غزه من وفي ابرازها حيت تل الهواء
وايضا منطقه الزيتون وحي النصر والصبره
والشيخ رضوان والشاطئ والتفاح هذه الغارات
طالت البعض منها منازل سكنيه ادت الى
استشهاد 14 فلسطينيا والبعض الاخر طالع
مناطق زراعيه ومناطق مفتوحه في خاصه
المنطقه الغربيه من مدينه غزه هذا تطور
لافت ربما يعكس ربما ايضا الروايه
الاسرائيليه التي كانت تتحدث عن السيطره
تماما على هذه المنطقه وتدميرها والقضاء
على المقاومه اليوم تعود الاشتباكات في
هذه المحاور وهذه المناطق التي شهدت منذ
بدء العمليه البريه على قطاع غزه تركيزا
للقصف وتركيزا ايضا في اعمال التدمير
والتجريف وتدمير البنى التحتيه ومن ثم
انسحبت القوات الاسرائيليه منها من ثم
الان تعود من جديد لتتوج وتحدث اشتباكات
وتصدي كبير من قبل فصائل المقاومه التي
قالت ايضا
انها قامت بالتصدي والاستهداف الاليات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه بعدد من القذائف
المضاده للتحصينات والدروع واطلاق ايضا
بعض من الرشقات الصاروخيه خاصه من منطقه
شماليه قطع غزه الى صوب البلدات
الاسرائيليه كما قالت سرايل القدس في بيان
لها كذلك كتاب المجاهدين قالت بانها اسقطت
طائره مصيره اسرائيليا في سماء مدينه غزه
وهذه تاكيدات بان المقاوم المقاومه لم
تنتهي وما تزال باقيه ايضا بالقرب من دوار
الكويت حيث انتظار النازحين قوافل
المساعدات تعرضوا لاطلاق النار من جديد
واصيب عدد منهم وصلوا الى مجمع الشفاء
الطبي نعود الى خانيونس حيث هذه المدينه
التي ما تزال تشهد عمليه عسكريه اسرائيليه
و تسمع اصوات اشتباكات بين الحين والاخر
في محاور التقدم غربي خان يونس في منطقه
المخيم الغربي وحي الامل عدا القصف
المدفعي المتواصل وتشهد ه المحافظه ايضا
غارات جويه اسرائيليه بين الحين والاخر في
مناطق عده في هذه المدينه كذلك مجمع ناصر
الطبي شهد وصول على الاقل تسعه من الشهداء
واجمالي الشهداء كانوا خلال ال 24 ساعه
الماضيه نحو 40 شهيدا وبحسب الاعلام
الحكومي خلال ال 48 ساعه الماضيه نحو 350
شهيدا في خانيونس لوحدها بفعل العمليه
العسكريه الاسرائيليه والغارات المكثفه
التي طالت احياء عدا في هذه المدينه الى
جانب ذلك تم دفن
35 شهيدا ومريضا بعضهم مجهول الهويه لعدم
تمكن ذويهم من الوصول اليهم ودفنهم في
المقبره الغربيه لتعذر الوصول الى مجمع
ناص الطبي تم دفن هؤلاء في ساحه المجمع
وايضا المقبره الرئيسه في خانيونس تشهد
حصارا وتشهد تدميرا وتشهد وجودا للاليات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه منذ ثمانيه ايام حيث
تتواصل العمليه العسكريه الاسرائيليه في
المنطقه الغربيه لخان يونس كذلك يتواصل
حصار مجمع ناصر الطبي ومشفى الامل وخروج
الخدمات الصحيه بشكل كامل محمد عن ال
الخدمه بحسب وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه فضلا
عن ذلك يتواصل اطلاق النار واستهداف في
النازحين في ساحه مشفى الامل وتعرض مركبه
اسعاف لاطلاق النار واصابه خمسه من
النازحين نقلوا الى النقطه الطبيه على
ساحل بحر مدينه خان يونس لعدم تمكن الطاقم
الطبي من نقلهم والتعامل معهم في ساحه هذا
المشفى الذي كان قد تعرض في وقت سابق لقصف
مدفع اسرائيلي وهناك حاله من الخوف والرعب
في صفوف النازحين تحديدا في داخل هذا
الماوى الذي يضم نحو 7000 نازح بحسب
الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني فضلا عن ذلك هناك
مح صر في نحو سته مراكز ايواء على الاقل
في محيط مجمع ناصر الطبي عدم مراكز الاواء
الاخرى في منطقه حي الامل وهناك مصابون
ايضا محاصرون في بعض مراكز اللواء بفعل
النيران الاسرائيليه المتواصله باتجاه هذه
المراكز الواقعه في المنطقه الغربيه لخان
يونس